Derek is in Chicago welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Derek how can I help I had a
few questions
me and my wife just kind of started
getting on the plan I actually led the
Total Money Makeover and I we just got
our thousand dollars saved up as a my
last paycheck and got our budget done so
last month and their lives we have about
$1,600 with the money going out there we
didn't really a counselor but my
question is is my my car that I said I
have currently my car and we have one
for my wife there's gonna be repo'd and
I'm trying to figure out exactly what I
should be doing and what I should get I
do drive 55 miles each way back and
forth to work they're going to be repo'd
yet I'm Melissa the account was closed
and just just the car that I Drive
currently right now the account was
closed so you're so far behind they just
said they're coming to pick it up yeah I
missed two payments and they got out of
40 days past due and that was I was
their hundred sixty days and how much
was your plane without you it was 380
uh-huh and so how many payments are you
behind now that's my building that's not
a hundred and forty days at 380 it gets
like they just got adding up the
payments everyone going forward was
always one pint they just kept adding it
up yeah but eight eight ten hundred
divided by 400 is four months not three
I could be off a little bit too well
okay all right so you're $1,800 behind
on the car what do you owe on it in
total about I think it was twelve
thousand five like that and what is it
worth maybe five or six who said
I looked it up before to see what it
would be worse it was only about five or
six it's a 2012 Chevy Cruze was about
eighty thousand miles on it you know
five or six on the dealer trade or on
individual sale individual sale okay I
want you to do some fresh research on it
you've given up on this car and I'm
afraid it's gonna make a bigger mess for
you then if you could figure out a way
to sell it and borrow the difference
because they're gonna take the car and
you're gonna sell it for a lot less than
you would sell it for and they're going
to come after you for the whole
difference I don't like that plan
yeah I called him a couple months ago I
first missed it and asked because I had
started watching the show and I asked
them if they would you know sign a note
for the difference and because I use one
of the bigger credit unions and I call
them and I said no we can't do that you
know the part of that credit wasn't good
enough and everything else ladies didn't
really want to work with me at all I
asked the people sighs okay well I mean
I would look for a different lender then
to see if you can find somebody I mean I
just I hate for them to come sell this
car for 3,000 when you could get six
maybe four it's yourself because it's an
extra three you're gonna have to pay
them because they're gonna come after
you for the entire difference you
understand that right yeah I know okay
all right well as far as what you're
gonna get to drive you're gonna have you
don't have any money I assume now we
have dollars to develop I mean like I
make a pretty decent income and you know
between well we're saving what's your in
there I was I make about eighty-five
thousand a year so why are you behind on
this corner we to the eyes we do is just
a lot of stupid mistakes a lot of things
doing and doing the wrong things and
only too many payments and wasn't my
only payment I had five three four
credit cards and my waist part other a
lot of loans I had about 150 thousand
dollars in debt okay and so how much is
your house payment I know how much is
your wife's car payment
about 385 how many kids do you have -
okay if you didn't pay anything but your
house payments and your car payments you
could pay triple car payments and get
this thing current and just keep it go
to that credit guy and sit down in
person and offer to pay them 1200 bucks
a month until you are thirteen hundred
bucks a month until your current and
they will do that I can't go to this
predicate unless they have a branch ID
I thought you said they had branches I
thought she said they were huge credit
union in your area okay we'll get on the
phone with them yeah
get on the phone yeah and see if you can
get someone can you make enough money
how much other dad have you got other
than these cars in your house besides
the car on the house maybe 40,000 okay
and what's that on I got about six or
seven thousand in credit cards and then
I got about ten thousand on one loan and
then my wife's cars about fifteen
thousand okay all right yeah keep your
wife car current tell the credit unions
to jump in the creek tell the $10,000 to
jump in the creek and get your car
current and keep it and then get on a
budget with your with your house and
your cars and keep them current feed
your kids and then catch up on the other
stuff after you do that your car is your
best bet
keep it and let's get it paid off and
get it current and then get it paid off
like we do everything else here once you
get current with everybody then you
start working your debt snowball but
right you make plenty of money if you
stopped your 401k have you stopped
everything else in your life that's out
of control spending so you can
concentrate on saving this car you and
your wife are working together and
you're on the written budget with every
dollar right
right hey I got that so long so I'm
right you can put 1,200 bucks on this if
you don't pay anybody but utilities
house payment food and her car you can
put 1200 right her car am i right yeah
yeah or more put all you can now put all
you can on it and get a current really
really fast and get this monkey off your
back you don't realize how much stress
you're carrying I can hear it in your
voice tone that's associated well it's
it's right it's riding your back pretty
hard it's a big old monkey on your back
and you get this thing current and you
get you keep your house your two cars
your utilities and your food current
food shelter clothing transportation and
utilities we call that putting up the
four walls then you go catch up the
unsecured creditors get on a plan with
them get them current then you start
your your debt snowball but not until
okay does that make sense to you that
makes sense and you're gonna be able
turn this around pretty quick once you
start paying attention to this and how
old are you - did you say 0.6 okay all
right have you guys been through
Financial Peace University yet no and I
did that last week actually gotcha and
this stuff takes a toll on your marriage
doesn't it well in just the freakout
that they're getting ready to come pick
up my car yeah there's a lot of freakout
going on I was your age when I went
broke with little babies in my house so
I remember how it feels to be scared so
I want you and your wife to go through
our Financial Peace University I'm going
to give you the one-year membership I
want you to get in one of the groups and
go to the nine classes and then I want
you to go through everything that you
can get to online there and and go to
the group's to go the group and learn
and get some people around you that are
doing this stuff walking with you
they'll encourage you you hold on I'll
have Laura pick up and we'll get you
signed up for a one-year membership on
Financial Peace University and every
dollar plus
we'll get this whole thing going for
your brother you call me back if you
need more help but that's what I would
do in your shoes thanks for calling in